hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zahlen minecraft also
zu einem neuen in minecraft video nicht
nur zu einem minecraft video also
natürlich ist es einen minecraft
videotextes dienstag meine damen und
herren das heißt heute kommt dass
minecraft beta let's play was ja seit
zwei wochen jetzt ungeschnitten
weitergeht
das heißt genau ab diesem zeitpunkt
jetzt werde ich nicht mehr karten
einfach nur musik im hintergrund und ihr
seht jetzt 15 minuten uncut luca lädst
du dich letzte mal waren wir hier stehen
geblieben und haben uns hier ausgeloggt
das heißt ich laufe jetzt erstmal diesem
wasserfall ihr hoch was eigentlich
überhaupt keine gute idee ist weil ich
ja noch tiefer in die höhle eindringen
will und eigentlich später auch noch
meine sachen wiederfinden will ich sie
auch gerade ich habe unten gar keine gar
kein richtiges schwert mehr und ich war
auch so klug und hab kein holz
mitgenommen das war auf jeden fall auch
super von di luca aber ich glaube dass
hier ist unser weg nach oben genau da
kommen wir gleich jeden moment mal nach
oben gehen ich nehme mir aber erst mal
ein bisschen reisen je mehr ich bin
schon wieder so übermotiviert und
versuche dieser herausforderungsrecht
werden zu recht gelingt zu werden dass
ich wirklich versuche die ganze zeit zu
kommentieren ohne auch nur eine einzige
pause zu lassen weil das habe ich halt
wenn ich nicht schnell und ich weiß
freundlich weiß in jedem minecraft hall
geht es irgendwie darum also neben
minecraft teil von diesem projekt geht
es irgendwie darum dass ich immer zu
beginnen oder irgendwann mittendrin sagt
ja eigentlich würde ich jetzt schneiden
nicht hindert mich aber gerade daran oh
mein gott ich sie ein schwein dahinten
alte das wird jetzt so lecker zerfressen
ich freue mich darauf wie man ja immer
geht's noch ne kuh
management ich glaub ich schon direkt
mein see bereinigt ob irgendwann sollte
ich mich wirklich auch mal darum kümmern
dass ich die teile wirklich irgendwie
vermehre so dass ich nicht irgendwann
überhaupt keine tiere mehr hier habe und
überhaupt nichts mehr zu fressen haben
aber das kommt noch irgendwann
freundlich weiß andere youtuber sind in
ihren projekten nach seiner zeit schon
auf dem mond gewesen oder so aber
ich mag oder sondern einfach nur
beschissene das heißt wir dürfen und
direkt ich es eben schnell dieses
komische rotten flesh auf so das ist
zumindest mal backup sicher sorgt beim
und jetzt laufe ich nach hause nutzt
jetzt das komplette eisen um mir
komplett neues werkzeug zu machen und um
dann wieder und es ist übrigens gerade
ultra heißen also nicht falls ihr fragen
zu wort denn unterhemd an um hat er eine
crêpe nach hinten so also es ist
wirklich us sind hier gerade ich weiß
nicht in meinem zimmer so 34 35 grad
oder so und das ist einfach nur videos
produziere eigentlich sind draußen
gerade die damen mit nur 24 grad aber
ich habe hier eine softbox komm ich zeig
dir softbox und ich schreibe mir
komplett nick schmerze aber ich dachte
mir ich schneide ich dumm was nicht
steigt ja diesmal gar nicht
das ist nämlich die sachen er
normalerweise müsste ich jetzt ok
typischer luca zeigt ebenfalls mit
seiner facebook setzt jetzt einen tollen
schnitt oder sony hier ist ja alles
uncut also ich weiss luca denkt sich
wahrscheinlich grad im schnitt ort hätte
ich da gern bestünden aber dann hätte
ich ich weiß ich glaube er hätte nicht
mehr erhält weil viele also es ist so
ein bisschen ist es mal so ein bisschen
ausgeglichen einige meiner jahr die
softbox flackert gerade aber einige
meiner solo erfolg blöd dass du nicht
schneidet aber hey wir haben noch
irgendwie fünf sechs andere videos die
woche die geschnitten werden und die
andere hälfte sagt und das ist eine
größere hälfte also es ist natürlich
auch nur hälfte aber das ist eigentlich
die märz hat das ist eigentlich keine
hälfte die sagen ja ist eine schöne
abwechslung dann hat man einmal einer
woche wirklich ein video von dir was
komplett clean ist wo du nichts in ihrer
nachbarn gemacht hast also damit ihr
mich seht dass ich hier zwischendurch
keine ahnung eine pizza fresse oder so
ich muss halt wirklich nur gerade
zwischendurch mal so ein bisschen ans
handy also ich bin
gerade in dem ich bin gerade noch zu
hause fahre allerdings weichen den
urlaub um meine eltern sind schon da wir
schreiben jetzt die ganze zeit auf was
sich somit bringen soll und dann so jo
wir bauen und diesen dann mit vergessen
deswegen muss ich zwischendurch die
ganze zeit ans handy das tut mir leid
aber ich hoffe das könnt ihr verkraften
also ich möchte auch gar nicht dass die
folgen hier die ganze zeit voll sind mit
luca redet darüber dass er gerne
schneiden würde oder dass er nicht
schneidet oder warum die dass die gründe
sind und bleiben sondern vielmehr ums
game geschehen ist hat mir meine mutter
war ganz groß geschrieben hat ich muss
mir das ganz gut angucken
ich werde aber nebenbei natürlich
gekonnt weiter moderieren und das handy
weg packen und ihr einfach nicht
antworten das ist nämlich super toll so
mach ich das immer kann ich euch
empfehlen in der beziehung mensch du
wenn ihr eine nachricht bekommen von
euren eltern einfach nicht darauf
eingehen ja okay jetzt hast du mich
wahrscheinlich dann wieder sehr viele
ältere zuschauer ich meine bei dem video
das war es auch oft sogar kamen dann
eltern an oder so ich rede schon so als
wenn die video der schon waren aber ich
meine zum letzten jahr war es oft sogar
kamen eltern um ändern so luca ja meine
videos wir schauen wie wir mit der
ganzen familie vom fernseher wenn unsere
beiden töchter sind fans und sagt doch
bitte nicht so oft so die sch wörter und
ich denke da so sagt gott dachte da
überhaupt nicht drauf ja nee also worum
es eigentlich gehen sollte in diesem
video war
worum es eigentlich auch schon im
letzten part geben sollte war eigentlich
meine scheiße friese weil wenn ich meine
ich hab mich übrigens auch gerade
hingelegt und wollte den jungs hier
stehen noch ganz viele es entscheiden
von mir weil ich die ganze zeit wie die
am pc sitzen vor produziere es wird
nacht supercool nämlich daraus pakets
müssen was zufrieden
hierzu wurden rein so und bleibt das da
drin
ich begebe mich in mein bett
und ich freu mich bring mal ganz kurz
diese schale weg ich setze jetzt ein
kart okay ich setze jetzt ist tut mir
leid ich gehe jetzt erstmal ganz kurz
hier in meine kinder in das team ein
einwand schlafzimmer und in der zeit wo
ich jetzt schlafe und aufwache
ich setze keinen cut okay von ich setze
keinen cut damit das ganze ankommt
bleibt so ich bring die schale nur
schnell rüber anderen raum weil er
stinkt es nach pizza bis 2000 jahre
später
ich habe sie müssen die horror vision
gerade ich bin extra richtig schnell
gelaufen
habt ihr wahrscheinlich gehört weil ich
jetzt am neuen filter an meine micro
drin habe dass ihr quasi nichts hört
auch wenn ich irgendwie nach dir geh
oder so dass schon leise oder wenn ich
nach biaggi oder nichts hören so dass
wirklich nur das aufgezeichnete dass
genau hier stattfindet weil bei mir auch
in nächster zeit so ein bisschen
bauarbeiten auf einer terrasse sind weil
der neues holz drauf kommt dazu ein paar
sachen passieren in nächster zeit aber
ich habe mich nicht weil ich angst hatte
ich kann nicht mehr sprinten weil ich
nichts zu essen habe ich hatte angst
dass irgendwelche zombies reinkommen und
dass die oder skelette oder das spinnen
hatten wir letzten zimmer weil er sonst
bei deiner nähe ist die mich direkt hoch
nehmen weil ich da irgendwie vergessen
da irgendwas auszuleuchten oder so da
hatte ich gerade wirklich so ein
bisschen angst deswegen habe ich ein
bisschen durchgezogen aber wir packen
jetzt das fleisch herein nehmen uns das
fleisch mit fressen das schön und dann
gehen wir auch schon ich würde wirklich
gern bei diesem kommen freunde wenn man
das jetzt mal ich weiß nicht ich kann
nicht sagen ob sich viele darüber
beschwert dass ich so lange in einer
höhle war allerdings kann ich sagen dass
ich neben dem weiter her gesprungen bin
ich kann mir vorstellen dass einige
nicht so konform mit gegangen sind dass
ich in den letzten zwei drei parts nur
nach höhle war also das fand ich selber
ich bin selber nicht so der höhlenmensch
also in höhe matches habe ich keine mehr
von uns aber ich wollte jetzt auch
endlich mal dieses haus fertig bauen das
nicht immer dieser pampa der penan muss
so ab hier drauf ich baute ich hier hoch
und dann müssen wir uns auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen sand holen kohle haben
wir eigentlich genug genau so rüber und
so und jetzt holen wir uns einfach mal
sand aus der wüste dahinten würde ich
sagen ich hab ja eine steintafel damit
sollten wir schon ein bisschen was
kriegen
ich überleg mal kurz wie viel wir
brauchen weil ich möchte daher relativ
viel glas hinsetzen
ich könnte ihnen raum eigentlich auch
noch größer machen aber das können uns
danach mal überlegen ich will das mal so
ein bisschen sand alles das was ich
kriegen kann das auch schön dass ich
überall die setzlinge hingesetzt hat
komm wir machen uns ja echt ein eigenes
ding
das katz ist jederzeit höhleneingang der
hier oder sei es der da vorne oder sei
es der da hinten oder der oder der alle
führen in ein riesiges höhlensystem und
irgendwo ganz unten ist eine schlucht
wohl auch items von mir sind irgendwann
werden wie die entweder finden und sie
sind noch da oder wir werden dieses
gestein des crazy oder wir werden sie
halt nicht finden
und das wäre dann halt sehr traurig na
ja ich nehme das eisen mit und wir
nehmen uns aber dann von hinten damit
wir nicht so blöd auf so eine riesige
fläche gucken
obwohl theoretisch könnte die ganze
fläche aushebeln als ich meine habe den
größeren sehen wir noch übel viel zucker
ob na ja ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal
von hiermit ist er komplett egal also
wunder nach hinten stellen dass er
nachher sofort wieder ganz oben dann
noch eine seilbahn haben wieder irgendwo
lang fährt wahrscheinlich wird luca das
projekt in zwei monaten beenden also in
acht oder so weil er keine lust mehr hat
oder so also nicht denkbar um die körper
ende des projektes zwei jahren in zwei
monaten zwei jahren wahrscheinlich in
zwei jahren lud genau zwei monaten weil
es jetzt einmal so gesagt hat habe ich
bin ja ein mensch so ich ändere mich
sehr das merkte ich glaube ich auch in
meinem content also ist es gibt so
youtuber wie paypal oder so was ich
überhaupt nicht negativ finde ich
bewundernswert dass er wirklich seit
gefühlt also ich verfolge keinen
deutschen youtube so richtig aber dass
er so weit von mir aus gefühlt einem
oder zwei jahren wirklich und ich sag
mal so den gleichen content und rhythmus
hat also
wenn wir mal so minecraft projekte dann
so ein paar andere gelbe projekt findet
ultra entspannt weil ich respekt vor
solchen leuten
ich selber kann sowas nicht ich kann
nicht sagen okay ich mache ein projekt
das geht weil sie nicht 100 folgen und
nebenbei habe ich noch zwei andere
merkwürdige gehen auch schon da bin ich
ein paar 70 80 oder so ich bin mir so
einer der jeden tag neue viele machen
will dass märkte wahrscheinlich daran
dass das tier mein einziges wirkliches
dauerprojekt ist sage ich mal so ganz
grob meine schaufel ist alle aber wir
haben auch schon mehr als genau 26 ca
von dem sand eingesammelt laufen
deswegen mal wieder zurück ich möchte
dass ihr lover folge heute so ein
bisschen ich bin ich bin bei zwölf
minuten
wie kann ich denn bei zwölf minuten sein
ich dachte ich bin dabei vier minuten
oder so what the [ __ ] you ich habe am
anfang irgendwie drei minuten kurz
aufnahme gemacht und der synchro
gestartet habt ihr nicht mitbekommen
aber lol oder don't believe we know it
seems to have zum gleis im detail stop
ich hatte übrigens okay wenn ihr das
video sieht nicht gerade aber er wollte
mich eigentlich nix machen essen hey ich
mache mir noch eine axt einfach eben
schnell damit ich ein wenig holz noch
holen kann
ich will unbedingt bevor die sonne
untergeht diese scheiß auf ok ich hab'
noch ein halber tag
es ist gerade wenn ihr das video seht
irgendwie anfang august
und ich will jetzt keine scheiße labern
irgendwie so weil bisher diesmal aber es
ist gerade einfach aus für mich das mich
irgendeiner wieder drauf festigt euro
und im topf war es gar nicht so heißt es
ist nur so heiß gerade bei mir weil und
es ist ultra heißt ich kann euch gleich
an meinen schweizer einer nahaufnahme
zeigen wenn ihr möchtet ich glaube das
wollte ich nicht aber ich habe gerade
zwei extra dummkopf okay gut vielleicht
habe ich doch schon richtig in ordnung
ich weiß noch nicht wie ich das machen
soll hier ich brauche doch eigentlich
eine tür oder so ich hätte ehrlich
gesagt bock hier so scheiße müsste das
normalpreis unterkommission hinsetzen da
habe ich jetzt aber richtig bock drauf
alter freund wenn ich war dann brauch
ich auch richtig hier ne so hier soll
kommission hinunter sollten zaun hin
jetzt habe ich gesagt einen zaun freund
ich weiß nicht ob ich das realisieren
kann mit einem zaun hier aber ich bin
auf jeden fall mein kumpel sollen wollte
ich ja eh schon den ganzen weg nimmt das
ganze ein bisschen schöner machen
also hier werde ich irgendwann noch
berge hinsetzen damit das ganze ein
bisschen meister aussieht also was
wollte ich sagen ja zu dem zeitpunkt wo
ich das video gerade aufnehmen hab ich
gerade eine englisch geschrieben die
lief eigentlich gut was heißt
geschrieben die als ich ja noch zur
union allerdings irgendwie gerade nicht
auf dem schirm wie solch eine klausur
schreiben aber hey wenn youtuber ersten
million abonnenten verdienst genug geht
es nicht so liegen muss ja aber youtube
ist für mich keine nicht was was ich auf
mein leben lang machen möchte also das
macht mir im moment spaß aber ich kann
euch sagen in zehn jahren wenn ich ja
nichts in der tasche hat einen bachelor
oder master oder ein doktor oder
irgendwas oder eine ausbildung oder so
dann bin ich möchte ich dann habe ich
auch meine meinung dessen komplett
anderes thema da muss ich mich auch muss
ich mich auch nicht für rechtfertigen
also ich wollte auch gar nicht dass ich
mich rechtfertigen nicht wieder so eine
scheiße
dafür wird die folge heute ein bisschen
länger gehen ok wird sagen wir gehen auf
die 20 25 minuten an dieser form einer
spitzhacke jetzt auch kaputt
kriegt man dafür immer schön mit ganz
gesucht die holz spitzhacken kurz das
thema zu vollenden ich hatte eine
klausur heute geschrieben bzw eine
mündliche klausur mit einem
studienkollegen von mir lief super
gegenüber ikea über die
internationalisierung von ikea und falls
euch fragt jolo carlos oft das thema im
letzten video schon angestellten ja es
ist heute quasi kurz danach nach der
letzten folge für mich nur dass ich die
zimmertemperatur von meinem zimmer seien
dann hatte ich schwitze man ich glaube
ihnen das video einfach mir ist heiß
ich komme man echt nicht klar ich bin
ich weil ich will keine neuaufnahme von
mir rat machen wie möglich um 30 grad
aussehe aber ich denke man sieht dass
hier alles ich bin dann sieht man
natürlich nicht bahnhof schweiz
naja es ist übel heiß jedenfalls habe
ich diese klausur geschrieben und es
lief alles gut und nachher wurden uns
halt fragen gestellt zu dem thema schon
wir waren überhaupt im thema drin und
habe total verschissen wiederum also ich
weiß gerade nicht auf die klausel als
super lief oder nicht also die
präsentation von uns warten hammer würde
ich sagen papa hat wieder irgendwas
geschrieben von vlingo kannst du
sozialen bild mitbringen also nicht mir
aber ich soll mir eine mitbringen weil
ich habe dort eigentlich eine wo ich
hinfahre aber dies irgendwie schon
benutzt worden hat auch keine ahnung
jedenfalls die klausur alter als wenn ja
manchmal kommt da nicht durch ok nice
ich dachte schon ich muss einen
komischen zaun bauen der so über eck
geht wisst ihr alter wie geil aber ich
bin in der beta hier ist ja noch nichts
irgendwie geil
deswegen schön kann ich so machen also
klausur geschrieben alles super dann
wurde uns fragen gestellt zu dem top
pick up display minecraft perfektes
relaxt lightning haben übrigens ab dass
ich so wenig rohstoffe nur noch habe so
viel glas bau ja eigentlich gar nicht
das war dumm gerade oder in den sand
einfach drin lassen können ist eine
flamme dummkopf
na gut wir haben ich nehme es einfach
mal die kohle ich war noch mehr
sollte scholz genau nehmen einfach mal
den baum hier vorne
so will das halt alles was ist denn
jetzt schon wieder ganze zeit in welche
nachricht war meine eltern also ich mag
meine eltern klar
aber nein okay ich will euch nichts weiß
ja ein paar jüngere zuschauer ich will
euch gar keine scheiße beibringen ich
dass ich jetzt die ganze zeit lang haben
sie mich es nicht geschafft mit dem
fertig zu werden bevor die sonne
untergeht
mann ich bin voll im englisch drin weil
ich gerade irgendwie 40.000 jahre
englisch geredet habe naja gut passt das
überhaupt alles 123 123 robot game star
natürlich schon cooler ausland liefern
hier anfangen würden kommt scheißegal so
hier kommen dann auf jeden fall auch
noch die sachen hin
ob es also nicht so so so so so so so
und da ja da manchmal auch ein hin ich
bin halt gespannt was da später aus
wertach übrigens auch eine höhleneingang
zu erhöhen
ich bin gespannt was hier aus wird also
kannst du die porsches und die fans also
ich habe keine zäune mehr
wie kann es sein dass ich keine zähne
mehr habe ich hab doch milliarden stück
gemacht alter
wie kann das sein dass ich so unfassbar
viele rohstoffe verbrauchen
zehn freunde geben wir nur alter ist es
deren ernst 10 war oder händlern creeper
ok 1 23 tag einen seite auch hier kommt
keiner mehr in fahrt
ja gut ich gehe mal wieder in meinen
raum da hinten und legehennen wir sind
schon mal minute 20 bei mir in der raw
datei muss ich wahrscheinlich wieder so
23 minuten abziehen oder so mein gott
was fällt dir dann einfach zu spannen
man ohne spaß sorry falls mein mikro im
garten besteuert oder so sieht einer
neuen einstellung aber hey schild zu
wenig kenne guckt mal ganz ganz anders
meine mom mir geschickt hat hatten sie
sorgen also wir gehen die wieder raus
hier raus wird für die blöcke hin gucken
uns um ich höre ihn spinnen stärkt meine
softbox macht komische geräusche ich
weiß nicht warum man sollte auch für die
ganze zeit auf englisch etwas raus zu
hauen weil das einfach nicht zu mir
passt ich bin auch schon kurz davor die
ganzen blöden höhlen eingängig einfach
mal zu machen
du hast du nicht die ganze zeit in
welche monster raus krabbeln soll man
irgendwie sogar noch mehr holz java
holzbau auch alter schwede
mir fehlt an allen ressourcen spielt
frag mich echt was sich in den
bisherigen parts von diesem projekt
gemacht habe ich habe einfach nur ein
projekt gesucht was ich jetzt rede ich
wieder über an kassen ist es echt so ich
leute wahrscheinlich einfach mal was
spielgeschehen kommentieren oder über
irgendwelche themen das heißt also den
nächsten part werde ich auch noch vor
produzieren
allerdings wird in dem wird in den
nächsten paar also wind schreibt mir mal
jetzt themen einfach so in die
kommentare ok über dich reden soll
und dann werde ich in den nächsten pass
über themen reden
zb wenn ihr mir sagt jo rede doch mal
darüber warum nun frosch im hals hast
dann werde ich darüber reden warum ich
ein frosch im hals
ich glaube ich muss das video jeden
moment beende ich weiß ja was ihr steht
aber mich fax übel ab dass meine top box
die ganze zeit am flimmern ist ihr müsst
übrigens wissen das equipment die fans
kennen die ich habe es irgendwie drei
jahre alt meine softbox ich hab eine
softbox es für ein youtuber ultra 2
beide rhinos weiteres bis 23
beide kamen von edun ab der die abwehr
ist beide chip in case you mend sind ich
glaube diese hüpfende spiel ist ein
zeichen dafür dass ich das video beenden
sollte wenn euch das video gefallen hat
meine damen und herren anlass doch gerne
like da mir macht spaß das ganze am cut
und kommt ihr zu machen
ich war heute kurz davor und zu setzen
dann aber raus gegangen habe ich einfach
daran gelassen
ihr dürft euch das nicht so vorstellen
von wegen ja was ich mal ganz kurz ihn
kurz raus hilft euch das nicht so
vorstellen von wegen naja ist auch
komplett egal ich habe jetzt schon 20
minuten gelabert ich glaube jetzt noch
ein video vor produzieren wir sehen uns
nächste woche im party repariert was
soll hass sei noch ruhig
danke jetzt geht's